- Oh they're different colors,
they're like party favors!
(upbeat music)
- Today we're going to guess
the price of period products.
- What's a period?
I'm just kidding.
- I remain generally oblivious
to feminine products.
- I get sent out a lot
to buy pads and stuff,
only pads though, I'm like the pad guy.
- Got styles, you got
colors, you got sizes.
- Shape.
- I had to Facetime my mom one time
'cause there were just so many pads.
- As far as like the cost of it goes,
I don't really have the slightest idea.
- I think it's a tampon.
- It looks super high tech.
- This seems pretty simple,
like simple technology.
- Wait, does that go inside of them?
- It does.
- Oh my god.
- Oh you push it up!
- There you go.
- You gotta, see?
- Oh you get two different sizes.
- You gotta vary throughout the cycle.
Because it rises and falls like the moon.
- 34 tampons will last you like.
I can't do that math.
- Yeah just like a bunch of cotton string,
like some cheap plastic.
- Probably about 10 bucks?
- Nine dollars?
- Maybe like this?
- What!
That's great, that's a steal.
- I just, they got me with that packaging.
- [Man] Diva Cup, I like the name.
- What the f... it's in here.
- Schwoop it in.
- Wash and reinsert, that
sounds like a lot of work.
- How do you wash this?
- Is this dishwasher friendly?
- You put this in the dishwasher?
- Wear up to 12 hours at a time.
- 'Cause it gets full,
your cup runneth over.
- This seems more expensive
though 'cause look at this.
- Yeah it's a nice material.
- Yeah the other one was just
like soft folded up paper.
- I think 20.
- 40 and I drew a little happy Diva Cup.
- 12.99
- I went with 15.99.
- What.
- Whoa!
- Oh my god!
- I'm offended for women
that this is so expensive.
- It's only one.
- You use it forever.
- The menstrual disk.
- Can't follow up the word
softcup with menstrual disk.
These things all sound so scary.
- It's cute.
Well your nipples are legal.
- To remove, hook your
finger under the rim,
slowly pull and then dispose.
- So it can't be felt
while wearing, doesn't,
can be worn during sex?
How?
- This is like, you know, my size.
(laughs)
Well, never mind, I take that back.
- The Diva Cup is like an electric razor
that you're gonna use
forever, and this one is like
one of those disposable
like one-time use razors.
- I'm going with 10.
- 20 dollars.
- 10 dollars.
- I am surprised that
these are more expensive
than the tampons though
because it's like, I feel like
tampons are more common
and like probably better.
- Simply summer's eve coconut
water cleansing cloth.
- Is this for when you don't
use any of the aforementioned
products and just kinda
have to clean up as it goes?
- Just remember front to
back, not back to front.
- If you have like a heavy flow,
this is not gonna help
you very much, I imagine.
- They help maintain a healthy pH,
making sure it doesn't
get too basic down there.
- Mmm.
- Whoa my god.
- This is a good smell
for any part of your body.
- Makes me think I'm at the beach.
- [Man] Water just went in my nose.
- I'm going five dollars, 4.99.
- It's my happy coconut.
- Thank god I don't have to
ever invest in these products.
There are so many different
confounding factors
that can go into this number,
maybe some women have
more flow than others
or some girls have their
period earlier than others.
- Definitely adds up.
- Absolutely.
Especially to lower income
women who probably can't
really be spending that much on that.
- And it has inelastic demand,
like you have to buy these products.
- Yes, exactly.
- I think if the roles were reversed
and men had periods instead of women,
I think that the world in general would be
a completely different place.
- Think about guys.
We don't really buy things
exclusively for, yeah.
- Biological purpose, maybe to shave.
- You can't really compare.
- There's no bar that has that
big old bowl near the door
that's just like, here's some free pads.
- I also think people would
try and get on top of it
and make it more affordable
and men would probably
be a lot more careless with it,
I feel like it'd just be blood everywhere.
- We don't really have
periods, it's just erections,
random erections but you
don't really do anything.
- [Man] You don't pay for
those, those are for free.